[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen
dieses samstags
immer mehr Opfer im Erdbebengebiet die
Zahl der Toten steigt auf mehr als
25.000 nach Tumulten müssen Helfer ihre
Arbeit unterbrechen
Visa Erleichterung für Überlebende
Bundesregierung will Türken und Syrern
die unbürokratische Einreise zu
Verwandten in Deutschland ermöglichen
und ein Gesicht der Wände
ex-ddr-regierungschef Hans Modrow stirbt
im Alter von 95 Jahren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mehr als 25.000 tote das ist die
aktuelle Opferzahl aus Syrien und der
Türkei die Vereinten Nationen gehen
davon aus dass sie sich mindestens noch
verdoppeln wird die Trauer schlägt
offenbar zunehmend in Wut um Berichten
zufolge gibt es Plünderungen und
Aggressionen auch weil es am Nötigsten
fehlt
wegen der Sicherheitslage haben mehrere
Rettungsteams in der türkischen Region
hartei ihre Arbeit unterbrochen dennoch
gelang es Helfern etwa in gaziante auch
heute noch Überlebende zu bergen
es gibt sie noch die Wunder auch nach
über 120 Stunden noch hier wird am
Morgen eine fünfköpfige Familie aus
einem Haus in Norddeich in der Provinz
Gaziantep gerettet doch es gibt auch
Rückschläge am Samstag erreicht die
Retter der deutschen Hilfsorganisation
Isa eine bittere Nachricht in einer
dramatischen Rettungsaktion hatten sie
gestern seine Karaman aus den Trümmern
ihres Hauses retten können doch die
40-Jährige starb starke schwächt am
Morgen im Krankenhaus
immerhin war sie ja über 100 Stunden
wirklich richtig verschüttet also nicht
eingeschlossen sondern verschüttet kurz
darauf mussten die Helfer von Isa und
Technischem Hilfswerk die Arbeit
einstellen aus Sicherheitsgründen in der
Provinz hathai waren Schüsse gefallen
die Stimmung wird aggressiver das ist
zum einen der Tatsache geschuldet das
jetzt Nahrungsmittel ausgehen dass die
Wasserversorgung ausgeht und dass die
Leute dann auf der Suche nach
Nahrungsmittel was das sind die eine
zweite Sache ist noch dass die Hoffnung
die man hatte jetzt zunehmend schwindet
und dass das diese Hoffnung dann auch in
Wut umschlagen kann
bei vielen liegen die Nerven blank in
Karaman Maras wird ein Ehepaar von
Anwohnern gestellt es soll verlassene
Wohnungen geplündert haben
Diebstähle werden auch aus anderen
Teilen der Krisenregion gemeldet das
türkische Verteidigungsministerium
schickte über 25.000 bewaffnete Soldaten
in die Erdbebengebiete um zu verhindern
dass Plünderungen und Gewalt eskalieren
wir haben den Ausnahmezustand erklärt
das bedeutet auch dass jeder der in
Verbrechen wie Plünderei oder Entführung
verwickelt ist die starke Hand des
Staates zu spüren bekommt
im syrischen Aleppo werden offenbar
keine Überlebenden mehr gefunden über
200.000 Menschen schätzen die Vereinten
Nationen sollen allein in Aleppo
obdachlos geworden sein dort traf heute
der Chef der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation gebe Jesus
mit einem Hilfstransport ein sondern
wir haben nothilfeausrüstungen und
andere Hilfsmittel gebracht das war
heute die erste Lieferung eine zweite
wird morgen folgen und es wird sicher
noch weitere geben
Aleppo liegt in einer von der syrischen
Regierung kontrollierten Region das
Erdbeben aber wütete auch in
rebellengebieten dort warten die
Menschen weiter auf Hilfe von außen
in den Katastrophengebieten stellen sich
zunehmend Fragen vor allem warum waren
so viele Gebäude nicht erdbebensicher
gebaut
Antworten finden sich dort wo trotz der
Erschütterungen die allermeisten Häuser
stehen blieben etwa im türkischen aderna
weniger Korruption weniger Pfusch am Bau
doch auch dort gibt es Tote und Leid
eine Brühl berichtet aus der 2
Millionenstadt
eine Schnellstraße intakte Hochhäuser es
erschließt sich nicht auf den ersten
Blick wie stark auch Adana vom Erdbeben
betroffen ist und wie schnell Sie hier
die Trümmer schon beseitigt haben hier
stand mal ein 13-stöckiges Haus erzählen
uns Nachbarn
so einen Krach habe ich noch nie gehört
danach dann der Einsturz von diesem
Gebäude wie eine Bombe die Schreie der
Menschen mir geht es psychisch nicht gut
einen Ingenieur der Stadtverwaltung ist
gekommen spricht mit den Nachbarn ihre
Häuser sind einsturzgefährdet eigentlich
darf niemand sie mehr betreten viele
versuchen aber trotzdem kurz das
Nötigste aus ihren Wohnungen zu holen
fünf Tage nach dem schweren Beben sind
in Adana fast alle einsturzstellen
geräumt die Toten geborgen wie viele
Menschen hier gestorben sind ist immer
noch unklar die Hilfe für die
Überlebenden hat jetzt Priorität in
einem Basar in der Innenstadt hat der
türkische Katastrophenschutz zählte
aufgebaut für die Überlebenden für die
die nicht mehr zurück dürfen in ihrer
Häuser Ismael sarah ist mit Frau und
drei kleinen Kindern seit Montag hier
zeigt uns sein Zelt
so kalt wird haben wir mehrere Decken
jeder hat drei bis vier decken
auch in Adana ist Sicherheit inzwischen
ein Thema alles in Ordnung sagt uns der
Polizeichef im Interview wir als Polizei
haben bei allen eingestürzten Häusern
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen getroffen wir haben
denjenigen die bei Rettungsaktionen
dabei waren geholfen wir treffen auch
Maßnahmen gegen Diebstahl
während der mit uns spricht haben seine
Kollegen auf der Straße einen Plünderer
erwischt
sie haben es gehört wegen der
Sicherheitslage haben Rettungskräfte wie
das THW ihre Arbeit unterbrochen fragen
wir Anne Brühe sie berichtet seit Tagen
aus dem Katastrophengebiet eine wie sind
eure Eindrücke wird die Stimmung
aggressiver
wenn wir zum Drehen unterwegs sind dann
begegnen wir eigentlich immer nur
Menschen im absoluten Ausnahmezustand in
extremen Situationen Überlebende andere
die Familienangehörige oder Freunde noch
unter den Trümmern haben und die
natürlich wollen das alles dafür getan
wird diese Menschen zu retten oder dann
noch wenigstens zu bergen und da ist
tatsächlich die Stimmung manchmal
aufgeheizt auch aggressiv auch wir haben
das schon erlebt was uns hier auffällt
ist dass in den letzten Tagen die
Polizeipräsenz enorm verstärkt wurde es
ist auch sehr viel Militär auf den
Straßen zu sehen in den Zähne Provinzen
des erdbebengebiets gilt ja auch der
Ausnahmezustand die Türkei will hier
ganz offensichtlich Stärke zeigen
danke für diese Eindrücke aus Adana Anne
Brühl
auch hierzulande leben viele die
Angehörige und Freude in den
Erdbebengebieten haben sie wollen
unbedingt helfen stoßen aber an Grenzen
wer zum Beispiel seine obdachlos
gewordenen Eltern schnell hierher holen
will tut sich derzeit schwer weil die
ein Visum für Deutschland brauchen jetzt
verspricht die Bundesregierung Hilfe
Petra Otto berichtet
seine Eltern haben das Beben überlebt in
Malatya Ostanatolien rannten auf die
Straße als das Haus erzitterte sind
jetzt notdürftig untergebracht bei
Freunden Mesut husch würde sie gerne zu
sich holen am liebsten schon morgen
ja die sind auch bedürftig weil sie
erstmal alt sind ich habe hier Platz ich
habe meine Möglichkeiten die sind dann
hier versorgt in warmen kriegen essen
aber ohne Visum können sie nicht kommen
und die visumpfpflicht sie gilt nach wie
vor normalerweise dauert der Antrag
Wochen jetzt haben viele nicht mal einen
Pass der liegt oft unter den Trümmern
die beiden würden Bergische
Landtagspräsidentin selbst kurdischer
Herkunft tritt seit Tagen für schnelles
Handeln ein entscheiden ist dass die
politische Haltung da ist dass man sich
den rückgibt und sagt ja diese
Naturkatastrophe erfordert pragmatische
Lösungen und deshalb wollen wir das
machen und wenn das wollen dann wird es
auch gemacht heute scheint sich auch die
Bundesregierung zu bewegen wir wollen
ermöglichen das türkische oder syrische
Familien in Deutschland ihre engen
Verwandten aus der Katastrophenregion
unbürokratisch zu sich holen können mit
regulären Visa die schnell erteilt
werden und drei Monate gültig sind ob es
jetzt ganz schnell geht und auch für
seine Eltern gilt die keine Dokumente
bei sich haben das ist wohl noch offen
Mesut hosch muss sich noch gedulden und
viele andere auch deren Angehörige im
Erdbebengebiet ausharren
wenn sie den Menschen in der Türkei und
in Syrien helfen wollen können Sie das
tun beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN lautet
de65-100 400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alle
Informationen gibt es auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890 oder sie scannen den
QR-Code
nach Berlin dort gab es bei der Wahl im
September 21 so viele Probleme und
Pannen dass das Ganze wiederholt werden
muss und zwar morgen dabei ist so
ziemlich alles offen ob SPD
Bürgermeisterin Giffey im Amt bleibt und
auch ob die Hauptstadt weiterhin
Rot-Rot-Grün regiert wird im aktuellen
Politbarometer lag die CDU deutlich vor
SPD und Grünen Silvia blessmann über das
Wahlkampf Finale gemeinsam trauern und
gedenken am letzten Wahlkampftag stehen
alle Spitzenkandidaten der
demokratischen Parteien zusammen mit
vielen Menschen der Stadt um Solidarität
für die Erdbeben Opfer zu zeigen Berlin
ist solidarisch und weltoffen betont die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin man habe die
flüchtlingskrise bewältigt und ein
Wirtschaftswachstum geschafft Franziska
Giffey will ihr Amt unbedingt behalten
wer regieren will muss eine politische
Mehrheit organisieren und wir haben ein
großes Interesse daran dass das Rote
Rathaus rot bleibt und dass die SPD
weiter die für eine Kraft in dieser
Stadt bleibt auch Bettina jarasch von
den Grünen möchte Bürgermeisterin werden
eine Linkskoalition unter grünerführung
ist Ihr Ziel sie will die Stadt umbauen
mehr Klima und Mieterschutz weniger Auto
unsere weil wir einfach wissen dass es
wirklich um die Entscheidung geht gehen
wir in den Grünen und gerechte Zukunft
oder blockieren wie die gehen sogar
zurück und deswegen ist diese
Wahlwiederholung auch eine zweite Chance
auch eine zweite Chance für Berlin auch
die Linken wollen weiter mit regieren
setzen auf ihr klares Votum für eine
Umsetzung des Volksentscheides zu
Enteignung großer wohnkonzerne und
Hilfen für benachteiligte in der
Energiekrise wir wollen konkret dass
sich die sozialen Verhältnisse
verbessern dass der sozialen Spaltung
entgegenwirkt wird die Mieten Probleme
angepackt werden und das haben wir in
den Mittelpunkt gestellt
selbstbewusst und optimistisch wird Kai
Wegner im Sport seine CDU führt in allen
Umfragen Silvester Krawalle und
wahlausbrachten der Stadt ein
Katastrophen Image das will er ändern
wir gehen mit dem Ziel in den Sonntag
dass diese Stadt ein politischen Wechsel
bekommt das Rot-Grün-Rot abgewählt wird
und dass wir einen Neustart hinbekommen
und ein Wechsel in Berlin ist nur
möglich mit einer ganz starken CDU
zumindest die FDP wird Wegener an seiner
Seite haben auch Spitzenkandidat
Sebastian Czaja sieht eine Chance zu mit
regieren wir wollen natürlich
ordentliches Wahlergebnis erreichen weil
eine starke FDP erst den Wechsel in
Berlin möglich machen wird und damit die
Chancen für eine Reform Koalition
steigen die AFD könnte zweistellig
werden profitierte von der chaoswahl und
den silvesterausschreitungen wir punkten
mit innerer Sicherheit wir punkten
natürlich auch mit dem Thema Migration
ungesteuerte ungeregelte Migration mit
dem Thema Clan Kriminalität bei der
Wiederholungswahl soll nun alles klappen
genügend Stimmzettel sein da heißt es
genügend geschulte Helfer auch ein
zweites Mal soll die Wahl in Berlin
nicht schiefgehen
schauen wir uns ZDF Wahlstudio zu
Bettina Schausten Bettina eine Frage ist
ja wie viele in Berlin sich überhaupt zu
dieser Wiederholungswahl aufraffen
werden
ja richtig und das ist ziemlich schwer
vorauszusagen dabei hängt ganz viel
jetzt davon ab ob und wie die Parteien
ihre Wählerinnen und Wähler mobilisiert
bekommen die Grundstimmung die hier
vorherrscht angesichts der großen
Problemthemen Verkehr Wohnungsmarkt
Kriminalität ist eine irgendwo zwischen
Unzufriedenheit und Gleichgültigkeit die
Arbeit des Rot-Grün roten Senats wird
mehrheitlich sehr kritisch bewertet aber
das ist eine CDU geführte Regierung
besser machen würde glaubt eben auch nur
eine Minderheit das sind schon Berliner
Verhältnisse die CDU hat laut der
Formfragen du sagte dass die Chance nach
mehr als 20 Jahren wieder stärkste Kraft
zu werden die Frage ob daraus dann ein
Regierungswechsel wird oder alles bleibt
wie bisher das dürfte den Wahlamt morgen
bestimmen wir melden uns hier ab 17:45
Uhr aus dem ZDF Wahlstudio in Berlin bis
dahin danke schön nach Berlin Bettina
Schausten war das
in Frankreich sind erneut
hunderttausende gegen die geplante
Rentenreform auf die Straße gegangen
allein in Paris versammelten sich
Gewerkschaftsangaben zufolge und eine
halbe Million demonstrierende am
Nachmittag kam es zur Ausschreitungen
die Polizei setzte Tränengas ein Grund
für die Proteste sind die Pläne der
Regierung des Renteneintrittsalter von
62 auf 64 Jahre anzuheben
erneut haben US-amerikanische Kampfjets
ein unbemanntes Flugobjekt abgeschossen
diesmal über Alaska es habe den zivilen
Luftverkehr gefährdet so ein
Regierungssprecher erst vor einer Woche
war ein mutmaßlicher chinesischer
spionageballon vom Himmel geholt worden
ob es ein Zusammenhang zwischen den
beiden Fällen gibt ist offen
in Hamburg haben rund 1000 Demonstranten
gegen die Menschenrechtsverletzungen in
Iran protestiert auf Plakaten und mit
sprechören zeigten sie ihre Solidarität
mit der iranischen Protestbewegung und
forderten ein Ende des mullerregimes in
Teheran feierte die Führung heute den 44
jahrestag der islamischen Revolution vor
10.000 Menschen erklärte Präsident raisi
die systemkritischen Proteste für
gescheitert
jetzt zu einem der nach dem Mauerfall
bei vielen Hoffnungen weckte auf eine
andere DDR sein Leben lang blieb er
überzeugter Sozialist heute ist Hans
Modrow im Alter von 95 Jahren gestorben
als Letzter ddr-ministerpräsident der
Staatspartei SED verhandelte modri die
Annäherung der beiden deutschen Staaten
bis ins hohe Alter kämpfte er darum die
DDR in ein besseres Licht zu rücken und
war bei der Linken aktiv Henriette de
Maiziere erinnert
er diente einen Leben lang seiner Partei
von der SED über PDS bis hin zur Linken
Hans Modrow ich denke ich habe eine
Menge in meinem Leben politisch bewegen
können wer sich ein böse dass man
überhaupt und politisch leben kann der
irrt sich der gelernte
maschinenbauschlosser Hans Modrow machte
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in der neu
gegründeten DDR schnellkarriere
studierte in der Sowjetunion
Wirtschaftswissenschaften einer der sich
auf der richtigen Seite wählte wir waren
schon der Überzeugung dass besser
Deutschland entsteht im Osten und von
dort wird einmal das vereinte
Deutschland entstehen im Wende Herbst
1989 wurde Hans moedro für viele zum
Hoffnungsträger der sed-bezirkschefin
galt als besonderer Politiker er ging
auf Bürgerrechtler zu verhandelte mit
ihnen am runden Tisch fünf Monate lang
stand der an der Spitze des
ddr-ministerrats begleitete die neue Ära
die Regierung der DDR ist bereit die
Zusammenarbeit mit der BRD umfassend
auszubauen umstritten in das bleibt
modros Rolle bei einem Polizeieinsatz
gegen demonstrierende im Oktober 1989 in
Dresden auch wegen des Vorwurfs der
Wahlfälschung wurde er nach der Wende
verurteilt auf Bewährung seinem
sozialistischen Weltbild blieb er bis
zum Schluss treu den schnellen Vollzug
der deutschen Einheit sah er stets
kritisch Hans Modrow ein durch und durch
politischer Mensch
jetzt zur Biathlon WM in Oberhof Norbert
gestern das erste deutsche Gold heute
lief es nicht so gut die Männer die
schwächelten heute etwas beim zehn
Kilometer Sprint bester Deutscher
Johannes kühn auf Rang 8 dafür räumten
drei Norweger den kompletten
Medaillensatz ab Gold und Silber ging an
die Brüder böhm
Heim der Beste der Besten und der
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
hat die ehrenvolle Aufgabe die besten zu
Ehren nach einem Fehler liegen der
Norweger Böhm beim Stehen schießen
zweimal im Glück im Nebel von Oberhof
dazu der schnellste auf der Strecke Gold
ist bereits früh vergeben besser
deutscher Johannes kühn bei zehn Schuss
neuen Treffer Rang 8 eine gute
Ausgangsposition für die Verfolgung
morgen das Podest aber ein rein
norwegisches Teil gewinnt Silber Bronze
Dollar Holm lagride
auch bei der Ski Alpin WM in Meribel
keine deutschen Erfolge beste
DSV-Athletin in der Abfahrt Kira Weidle
auf Platz 8 Jasmin Flury aus der Schweiz
holte Gold dagegen gleich vier deutsche
Weltcupsiege im Eiskanal
überraschend vor allem ihr Triumph Lisa
buckwitz mit ihrem ersten Weltcup
siegemonobob in Innsbruck Sieg vor der
Australierin Walker Weltmeisterin Nolte
fünfte ganz vorne aber Lisa buckwitz und
ganz vorne auch die deutsche Rodeln
Elite im Winterberg Max Langenhahn im
Einzel mit seinem dritten Weltcup-Sieg
in Folge bei den Doppelsitzern wendel
alt na Sieg heute wieder die führenden
im Gesamtweltcup und last but not least
bei den Frauen nicht zu stoppen scheinen
Rosenthal und Jessica Degenhardt heute
hat einfach alles ein bisschen gepasst
und ich bin mir sehr glücklich das ist
endlich mal geklappt hat in Winterberg
und Innsbruck heute die deutschen Teams
das Maß der Dinge
ja und endlich sind auch wieder die
deutschen Skispringer erfolgreich dank
Andreas Wellinger in Lake classic
gewinnt er durch einen
125einhalb Meter Sprung im zweiten
Durchgang vor dem Japaner Jojo Kobayashi
das ist sein vierter Weltcupsieg Karl
Geiger Achter Markus eisenbichler drei
deutsche also in den Top Ten
zur Fußball-Bundesliga da feiert der BVB
seinen sechsten Pflichtspiel Sieg in
Serie durch den Erfolg in Bremen jede
bisherigen Ergebnisse des 20 Spieltags
Werder unterliegt Dortmund 0:2 München
gewinnt klar gegen Bochum mit 3:0
Hoffenheim verliert auch mit dem neuen
Trainer matarazzo 1 2 3 gegen Leverkusen
Mainz besiegt Augsburg mit 3:1 Freiburg
schlägt Stuttgart durch zwei Elfmeter
Tore 22:1 das Abendspiel Leipzig gegen
Union und bereits gestern trennten sich
Schalke und Wolfsburg 0:0 Blick auf die
Tabelle die Bayern bleiben erster drei
Punkte der jetzt Dortmund Union Dritter
Freiburg erstmal rauf auf Rang 4 vor
Leipzig Frankfurt 6a die zweite
Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit Gladbach ja
unter einem Tabellen Ende alles
unverändert Stuttgart 16 vor Hertha und
Schlusslicht Schalke
ja und das Topspiel Leipzig gegen Union
bei uns um 23 Uhr im Aktuellen
Sportstudio tolle Besucher Rudi Völler
kommt und DFB-Präsident Neuendorf ja
freuen sich schon alle sind gespannt
denke ich der Sonntag wird nur im
Südwesten länger sonnig ansonsten gibt
es viele Wolken die Details hat gleich
Christa orbin das heute journal um
Viertel vor elf mit Christian Sievers
und hier übernimmt morgen mit Siri danke
für Ihr Interesse ein schönes Wochenende
noch und auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend die Tage werden jetzt
wieder länger die Sonne kräftiger zeigen
konnte sie dies heute aber nur im
Südwesten sonst gab es viele Wolken und
das ist auch morgen mit diesem
Hochdruckgebiet so ab Montag sorgt das
stabile hoch dann aber dafür dass ich
auch im Rest des Landes wieder häufiger
die Sonne zeigt in der nacht verhindern
die Wolken jetzt erst einmal die
Auskühlung frostsicher es ist nur im
Süden mit bis minus fünf Grad hier auch
oft klar der Wind im Nordosten lässt
schnell nach aus den Wolkenfeld vor
allem am Nordrand der Mittelgebirge
immer mal wieder Sprühregen das gibt
vereinzelt Glätte im Bayerischen Wald ja
den den Frühstunden da bildet sich im
Süden und in der Mitte dann verbreiteten
Nebel morgen Vormittag ist es dann eben
auch häufig hoch nebelartig bedeckt
stark bewölkt letzte Tropfen fallen
Richtung Osten hier auch am Nachmittag
noch die kontakteste Bewirkung im Westen
kann es mal etwas auflockern am längsten
sonnig ist es ähnlich wie heute im
Südwesten des Landes der Wind weht nur
schwach um das hochzentrum im Norden aus
West im Süden aus Ost in Ostbayern dann
auch am kühlsten mit zehn bis sechs Grad
sonst erreichen wir meinst 8 bis 11 Grad
und die Temperaturen in der neuen Woche
hängen sehr davon ab ob die Sonne
scheint dann sind bis 12 Grad möglich
oder ob der Dauernebel bleibt dann sind
es nur vier Grad es wird aber eine
ruhige erste Wochenhälfte mit einer
typisch winterlichen
sonnennebel-mischung tschüss